want to ask you about something you
you're doing drive
because you are a machine i you are one
of the most prolific
comedians high voiced effeminate
comedians that i know
you are you churn it out like nobody and
it's quality stuff i say turn around
to like me go on sorry
worth the interruption but no one works
as hard as you
you're doing drive-through comedy shows
where at a time when no comedian can be
working how does that work people
driving in their cars and they sit in
their cars and watch you perform
well you know the thing you know in this
time of
pandemic it's important for people to be
safe
but also uh so i've done a couple of
them
you go on stage in a parking lot and you
perform for cars you feel like
you know like you're recreating the
movie cars but
it is it's pretty surreal it's
you know uh you you can you see the
people or you just see a lot of car
you can see some you know it's a lot of
it's you know and i did a show marina
opened for me
and uh you know but what are you gonna
find out from even the comic who goes on
before you're like what's what's the
crowd like
there's a bunch of imports you know i
mean like there's some suvs
there's no uh electric cars yeah that's
fantastic
very nice they're volunteering to
recreate the experience of being stuck
in traffic
so how do they let you know
i mean can you even hear them laughing
can you hear them applauding
flashlights or b porns like they do a
polite kind of like
get out of the way if they like the joke
they're like yeah
you know kind of like move it along or
i'll run you over
they do that kind of beep and then at
the end they just lay on the horn
that's really nice i love that i think
there's something kind of inspiring
about that
that's people coming together it was
this it was a nice moment of
uh community it's nice to get feedback
you know i mean but it was weird you
know it's kind of like
everything's about food for me it's kind
of like if you hadn't had ice cream
for five months because of a pandemic
and then you had to eat like
non-dairy ice cream right
right i can see it's not quite the
stand-up experience
but it's as close as you're going to get
right now yes
i have a question for you you have your
i think you're the only comedian
with his own serious channel uh and that
is quite a that is quite an
accomplishment
this is a i i mean i congratulate you
only comic
i was i was very flattered uh they
they asked me and i was like because you
know
i'm unemployed essentially i was like
this is very exciting
i asked my manager what you know what
does it pay and he's like nothing
it pays nothing oh um but
uh it's also it gets better apparently
i was i was excited about it and then i
was talking to
i was doing press and somebody revealed
that
i'm channel 790 and do you know how many
channels there are
on uh siriusxm i don't
790. i'm 790. you're the last
channel i'm the last channel you'd think
that there'd be a channel that just gave
farm reports or something that would be
792.
you're the last channel i'm i feel like
i'm
participating in some make-a-wish thing
and i'm the beneficiary and i don't know
about it
right right you are live streaming your
family dinners
good ideas dinner dinner with the
gaffigans
and it gives us a glimpse into the
madness
of your life and i've watched this
it's crazy because you have all these
kids
at last count i think in the 20s 30s
and your wife everyone's talking at once
sometimes you're talking but sometimes
you're not talking
sometimes you just sit there and eat
your mush well you know the thing is
is it started off as this
you know thing
you know nice thing to do you know we're
all i thought we'd be in quarantine for
a couple weeks hey you know there's some
single people there's some grandparents
that are away from their kids why don't
we
do stream our dinners it'll be a nice
thing we'll do it for a couple weeks
five months later we're still doing it
and it's
it's what you know we've added a
fundraising element but like i gotta be
honest there's some nights
where i just don't want to do it kind of
like how you're handling this interview
i just kind of like don't want to do it
but i do it anyway
do you know what i mean and you know how
much i get paid for that nothing
it's kind of like a satellite channel
but yeah
you get paid for this interview i mean i
think i do
i believe jeff does he get paid how much
hello how much do i get six no
yeah jim gaffigan please now i know he's
there
we'll get him on the blower no no he's
on right now i'm on the other line just
listen
600 overs you're getting over 600
dollars for this appearance that's more
than you get from dinner with the
gaffigans
that's more than you get from the
serious channel that's more than you get
from mentioning sizzler four times
that's a lot of money i think sizzler's
out of business right
i don't think you're gonna get money
from them now
what are you gonna have for dinner
tomorrow tomorrow
you know you gotta have a lean fish
a lean fish and some vegetables you like
the way i say lean fish
also a lean new england people you guys
eat all those bugs from the ocean yuck
hate cod i eat cod not because
it's hard but because it's easy